the iPhone 15 lineup is coming in less
than three months and the leaks and
rumors are starting to get so good that
if you're considering upgrading to the
iPhone 14 right now stop because you are
going to regret it and I'm going to
prove it to you in this video by going
through the latest iPhone 15 leaks and
rumors so let's get right into it here
is the first one we've got to start off
with and this is for the pro Max model
the 15 Pro Max now this is very
interesting the image sensor the 48
megapixel camera is going to be the same
as on the current 14 pro Max however we
are getting a telephoto camera with
variable Zoom that word right there
variable is very important because a lot
of people think the Periscope cameras
are really good because they can go up
to five or six x Zoom but this is
variable with a different range now
unknowns 21 on Twitter actually found
out through some research what the
design of this this new Periscope camera
will look like so you have the lens on
the outside then you have a mirror
that's going to reflect the light then
another mirror on the other end and a
sensor all within one package so really
do on Twitter sketched it up as you can
see right here this is what it could
look like this module right here the
lens the prisms with all the interior
lenses and the sensor and here's an
actual render something like this is
what it could look like now before I
move on our sponsor Banks Max a battery
pack has a 10 000 milliamp hour capacity
that can charge three phones at the same
time with the additional USB A and C
ports on the sides and it has a nice
grippy matte finish and you can get it
with or without a stand for a killer
price with their Father's Day discount
using the links below now of course this
isn't going to be the first of its kind
because Sony's Xperia 1 4 was actually
the world's first true optical zoom lens
in a small smartphone and this right
here is what it looked like you have the
lens that comes in and then multiple
lenses on the inside and a side mounted
sensor and just to give you a better
idea here's a video from Sony themselves
here is the Periscope variable zoom and
there you go you can see the glass on
the inside moving back and forth and
that is how it does true optical zoom
and by the way if you didn't already
know Apple uses Sony sensors and cameras
and their iPhones because they are
literally the best they buy it from Sony
so why would an apple grab this variable
Zoom Periscope and put it into the 15
Pro Max that is what I think is going to
happen and because apple is doing this I
think we're gonna have the best
telephoto zoom camera in any smartphone
with the 15 Pro Max and that's because
Apple has really good software now
getting into the next one we have
confirmation that both the display and
the main camera are going to be the same
as the 14 pro Max which means the M12
panel is going to be unchanged so don't
expect any display changes at all with
the new one except for the larger size
and the bezels as I'll show you in just
a minute but the actual panel will be
staying the same we also have
confirmation that we're going to have a
three nanometer a17 bionic chip which is
going to be amazing huge change compared
to the current a16 in the 14 pro Max and
it's going to get an upgrade to eight
gigs of RAM finally we're not only stuck
with six gigs like we have right here
and it's going to be LP ddr5 which is
going to be really nice and upgraded now
if you are wondering when we're getting
an upgraded 48 megapixel camera it is
going to be with the 16 Pro Max or Ultra
when we're going to have a 1.14 inch
sensor which is going to be the IMX 903
that's coming thing next time not with
the 15 Pro Max so that's a little bit
unfortunate but it's okay because this
camera is really really good and by the
way that has been confirmed by shrimp
Apple Pro as well which is the leaker
who leaks the dynamic Island so we could
definitely trust shrimp and now before I
get into some exciting news for the
regular iPhone 15 and 15 plus models
I've got to give a shout out to our
partner case coup for their magic stand
case which is the best value case you
can get since it's very rugged high
quality and stylish while also featuring
magnets for all of your magsafe
accessories but making it even better
the max safe ring is actually on a hinge
that works as a finger grip and a stand
at a variety of different angles for
things like watching videos or even
taking photos so go ahead and check out
the discount info and Link down in the
description below and now getting into
the regular iPhone 15 models sources are
thinking that that model will be getting
an uplift in terms of sales due to a
major camera Improvement and that is
actually a rumor by Jeff boo saying that
the new regular iPhone 15 models are
getting the 48 megapixel camera like the
current Pro Models have I honestly
didn't think that was coming so soon to
the regular iPhone 15 models but it is
it is coming and that's going to be a
big deal because using Pro raw with that
48 megapixel camera is amazing the
quality gets so much better and if you
think Apple's gonna do something crazy
like add a third camera for telephoto
they are not we had a confirmation from
unknowns 21 that we're gonna have to
wait until the iPhone 16 for a vertical
camera layout like the iPhone 12 so up
and down which means still no telephoto
even next year with a 16 but this here
is iPhone 15 is going to look the same
the same as it was before for the past
couple of years diagonal camera layout
and that's exactly what unknowns 21 is
saying so it's a little bit
disappointing design wise and yet
another disappointment for the regular
iPhone 15 is that only the iPhone 15 Pro
Models are supporting USB 3.2 with much
faster transfer speeds because if you
didn't already know all of the iPhones
for the last couple of years supported
USB 2.0 with only 480 megabits per
second speeds yes this one on the 14 pro
Max and the new iPhone 15s are limited
to the same USB 2.0 even though they're
getting a USBC connector that is
horrible that's embarrassing for the
regular models and only the 15 Pros are
getting speeds as fast as 5 gigabits per
second and because the switch to USBC
across the entire iPhone 15 lineup it
looks like apple is working on some new
accessories with USBC ports instead of
lightning so iOS 17 beta code was
referencing a new Max a battery pack and
a new charger so it's nice to see apple
is working on those new accessories
another really great thing is that the
iPhone 15 series will be the first one
to support qi E2 wireless charging which
is going to unlock 15 watts of wireless
charging without official certified Max
name that means you're going to be able
to buy third-party Chargers with 15
watts charging which is the current
limit and that likely means that the
actual Max save is going to be even
faster than 15 it's likely going to go
up to 20 watts with the actual Max save
but honestly 15 has been more than good
enough right now with the 14 pro Max so
I'm very happy it's going to support G2
with those speeds and now here is
something a little bit disappointing to
hear from Tech Reeve on Twitter he says
that apparently the new a17 and M3 chips
are not completely new architectures but
rather improvements in the manufacturing
process to make it support three
nanometer so maybe it's not going to be
as good as we thought even technically
on three nanometer that's going to be
pretty disappointing but I honestly hope
he is wrong in this case and then of
course we have these League
the 15 Role Models getting the ACT
action button finally replacing the mute
switch that we've had literally Forever
on iPhones that's going away but only on
the Pro Models not on the regular one so
you're going to be able to customize
that action button to do different tasks
for example taking photos or video in
the camera app and a bunch of other
things that are going to be customizable
and then finally here is the huge bezel
Improvement on the iPhone 15 Pro Models
you see the pro and the pro Max and
those bezels are insanely Slim So Much
Slimmer than the ones we have right now
I am personally very very excited for
that because it's going to make it feel
a lot more immersive and a lot more
premium so there you go those are the
new refreshed updated leaks for the
iPhone 15 series coming in under three
months if you're excited let me know
down in the comment section below and
click the circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
one
[Music]
foreign